you ever see a guy go to the gym and he
says okay we'll do as when we're done
but what happens is I have this thing I
call Lima Bean theory he goes in there
he does shoulders he gets this big pump
and then after the fact when he's
supposed to do abs lima beans LMA Bean
theory is you're sitting at the table
your mom made macaroni and cheese
chicken nuggets and these stupid
llama beans just eat the Llama beans
first when you have the most energy
pre-workout excited to be there whatever
get it out of the way then you can enjoy
the chicken nuggets and the macaroni and
cheese you know it's like goes back to
eating as a kid do it first because
you're not going to do it after